I've just been handed a note that Gary
has a huge bowl of plantain chips
it's a plantation both I'm still still
dissing the plantains
dude I thought you're trying to lose
weight
yeah plantain chips [ __ ] guy every
time he gets on that microphone it's
like a like an eating orgy how about for
four hours not eating he's grazing I
mean is it that hard to wait till the
show is over
I'm grazing more plantains just like
bananas it's really very good
Gary's all upset cuz Jason told on him
about the plantain chips Gary get you
yelling at Jason he's just reporting
[Music]
during a blow to ha order he was so
angry and the thing is I had already
just iced it right next with all I said
to him every time I go on the on the mic
with him he's eating he said you can't
skip four hours in office he doesn't
come - and then he gave my office I go
Jason stay the [ __ ] out of my office so
then he put gives you and no and I said
I told you to stay the [ __ ] in my office
oh that was afterwards I go no was it I
told you stay at my office and he still
gave you a note I don't want into my
office I need some degree of privacy can
I just see the ball of plantains you do
by the way Gary just hid them in his
drawer just hide them
go I think it's Rory let me see it's
like oh it's a big table you didn't
report accurately Wow both he did it on
purpose because he knew he was gonna go
to you honey Mike he said like I'm gonna
legs I'm standing on and you tell Howard
this on the Mike and then the next thing
you did you threw plantains in your
mouth why did you do that why does
anyone I don't know damn why do you I'm
sorry Kay you're right I thought you
were the type of guy that knew when he
finished swallowing I apologize from his
reading the situation
[Music]
okay mr. plantains get all that done
because they said you have a table at
camp we have a camera on in your office
Gary you're in you're in turn out the
camera that no do you get a new
treadmill I heard oh yeah we're trying
out a new pallet on treadmill for URI
did you or did you not get a new pallet
on treadmill the tryout I did not um
when I I heard some about let's see
which one's triple two and four okay so
when you heard is wrong by the way
between you and me Gary isn't that an
[ __ ] move of will once the [ __ ]
moves selling on the cookies is supposed
to be selling ah wise will selling the
cookies for dude you're my man what kind
of douchebag move is that terrorizing
the office why you just asked everybody
for 20 bucks
had the same concerns but no what do I
do I'd take the [ __ ] here do I take the
[ __ ] at home I put the signup sheet on
my desk and people just started doing it
I like my desk let me see you're kind of
a senior guy around here the guys who
you know these guys if you [ __ ] they
buy cookies from you and it got weird
quick about I agree what do you mean he
got weird quick thank you forever timing
in like oh I can't wait to buy cookies
from you and you are in a position where
it feels weird that they're buying
totally inappropriate I agree
it won't happen again a lot of time yeah
buy something for the staff I brought
three like this under control I mean
there's no limit with you yeah what are
you gonna do leave them here and eat
them or you gonna no no I already did I
bought eight boxes three I left here we
brought them to a meeting for other
people to E and 5x did you eat them
already
I ate the tags all the Tagalongs are
gone I mean I 2 boxes a Tagalongs I
killed them this round what do you weigh
in there good [ __ ] around 300 I got all
excited because I was under 300 the last
time I weighed in at the doctors what do
you want a cookie I did I